hi there I'm James Williams associate
editor at Glamour general lover of all
things food fitness and health so I'm
super excited today to be in the company
and the kitchen of one deliciously Ella
of Instagram an internet sensation an
amazing food writer also responsible for
one already huge hit cookbook and soon
to be this truck yeah thank you first in
first of all before having it's my
pleasure really really exciting time
second book I know can you believe it no
honestly if you told me this time last
year that I'd be here when believe
during a second
and obviously it's called delicious
yellow every day there's a little bit
about how it's different in the first
book so I found so much of what I hear
from people when I talk about health
eating was there a few barriers that
people really felt which is that the
food wasn't accessible you know that it
was all these bizarre ingredients from
foreign countries that they never heard
of you know like spirulina
and you know so it wasn't accessible
that therefore those assumption be
really expensive because all these are
ingredients that you have to go
somewhere to get and then it'd be really
time consuming and then you wouldn't be
full you know or satisfied and so I
really wanted to show people it doesn't
have to be about that so this book is
about you know carrots notes and stews
and kind of you know real [ __ ] for
normal food and quick you know because
again like this as I said that people
think is very time-consuming complicated
and actually like you know I'm the crazy
psycho busy at the moment and I know me
and like I've I need I need to eat and
so you know I'll make you know in the
fridge Bertram muesli or try a pots or
something and they
two minutes ix Forge Burt turn a lid on
and then just take them with me yeah I
love this whole philosophy things like I
said I think people have this perception
that healthy eating and fresh eating is
a fan for example I mean it's not it's
just not you knowing so I just want to
show people that's not and that you can
do it in a really delicious way but
still keep it simple you know without
you know in create recipes that have
five six ingredients not 12 yeah and
doesn't matter how frazzled that have
busy day you've had
don't reach the takeaway there's only a
five minute exactly like somebody so
exact I'm going to prove it to you today
yes okay let's get going okay so it says
as we start by just making our pesto so
you just throw pineapple fresh basil
salt
I don't really why I like it this is not
an insanity it's a huge amino and it's
all ingredients that you know yeah you
know like none of these ingredients and
things you look at and you're like oh
that might taste funny presenting people
with meals that they look at and they're
like yeah I know what that is you know
it's like a healthier twist on something
familiar rather than something that you
look at and you just think what on earth
is that as you said you know when you
get back from work you know the last
thing you wanted to be doing is chopping
this and frying that and just like
running around the kitchen print our to
make a meal and just feeling really
strength
I know smells so good it looks so good
you know like how easy is that that's
quicker than going for tickets to buy
and then all we do is we just want to
drain our beans there's the best beans
but you can use any others just throw
them in a pan and it's just they've been
amazing brilliant cheap like really
filling your fiber with a salt to them
and then we want to add another lemon
just get some birds strongly so lemon so
much I thought no we're also the best
man and salad dressing exactly lemon and
olive oil just so simple absolute
delicious
also I think it's a very nice profit to
live your life food wisest if you know
everything needs exactly exactly someone
who does Finnegan well was he by the
Pacific West England supermarket example
there are 70 candles and things you
don't exactly and actually doesn't taste
any nicer then there so we're just gonna
wilt this for a minute and then we're
going to stir in our pesto I know it's
amazing
i annotate it also makes everything look
nice I can make a lot of stews and
curries and things in the winter it's
much easier than kale I know Carol's the
kind of popular one can I ask who it was
the most skeptical person in your life
is now totally come around to the fishes
the other way of eating you know dad's
so it's getting more sensitive quite a
traditional easy really sessional and he
was just that you're insane
things like but all my family have come
round my mum's for vegetarian this is a
very veggie they all eat very much the
way I do things just going so well
you've recently opened you
of Delhi yeah how much of a dream come
true is that that honestly the day that
I went over and saw the sign had been
finished painted you know with the name
on the front that was one of the most
kind of surreal moments before that
we've been working safe Aegis is just a
building site you know it didn't feel
real and then suddenly think oh my god
this is on a street like my name's on a
street you know I'm what kind of stuff
do you really expect people belong to
Delhi with this kind of Sanjiv like so
we're gonna have stews and curries and
pastures with brown rice pasta and then
we're gonna have the sweet treats all
right lots of things like this and you
you mix and match and make a bowl up of
different things so I haven't you know
I've roasted sweet potato wedges and
things like that I'll be there as much
as I can because it's so exciting it's
like a real dream come true and I wanna
for me what's so exciting is I love
seeing people like eat - 2016 is giving
up to be another piece how you say you
an exciting year yeah we also get
married yeah Corsican tell me you're not
thinking your own wedding
no I mean I met I will definitely be
involved in menu planning okay so he's
got amazing and that's that really I
like putting pomegranate song just you
especially if you're giving it to anyone
else just looks you know you you know
you can eat that on its own or you know
some brown rice or some quinoa some make
roast vegetables and it's just so that's
so easy
hmm we're gonna go
I left thank you so much that's
absolutely delicious I'm definitely
gonna make that again at home when I
suggest you or you all give it a go as
well from this recipe and lots of other
lovely recipes mellow check out the
April issue of bandages on sale right
now and let thanks so much Roger thank
you